let's take a brief break from the
potentially uh impending arrest of
failed former president Donald Trump to
talk about why the modern American right
wing loves authoritarianism and
authoritarian leaders you know it's
important to contextualize phenomena
that we observe in the modern world one
such phenomena is indeed one such
phenomenon is that modern Republicans
and right-wingers and mega trumpists and
and so on just seem to have a real soft
spot for increasingly authoritarian
policies and declarations why is this
and how did this come to be first and
foremost when we talk about
authoritarianism at its core what we're
talking about is a political system in
which the government has massive amounts
of power and authority over its citizens
it's a system that values control over
freedom and it relies on obedience and
compliance from the population why
does that sound weird when we think
about Republicans well it sounds weird
because it's the opposite of what they
claim Republicans have claimed for a
long time and still do
that they're about freedom and liberty
and not regulating people and not
regulating corporations and yet they
abandon those principles immediately
when the outcomes would conflict with
their worldview and they also seem to
glamorize the authoritarian leaders of
other countries and this includes under
Mega trumpism everybody from Putin and
duterte to bolsonaro and Orban and so
many others erdogan and many others that
we've talked about so why is it that so
many modern right-wingers are attracted
to this type of system there are a few
reasons and it's a combination of
fear-based motivation ignorance now some
of you might just say dumb Schmucks okay
I'm being a little more respectful and
I'm saying ignorance of facts and a
desperate desire for power those are the
three aspects that I would point to and
we can talk about each of these let's
first talk about fear
fear-based politics works much better
with Republicans as your targets and
when I say Target let's be honest
Republican voters are the targets of
Republican elected officials Republican
elected officials have accurately
assessed that in part because of what
have been quite frankly called brain
differences in right Wingers as well as
uh sort of value systems
right Wingers are very afraid of change
they're very afraid of others they're
afraid of difference and so it's really
effective to use authoritarianism as a
way to maintain control even if they
want freedom and liberty because you
tell them as a right winger as a
right-wing elected official folks all
these things you're afraid of
Twitter censoring conservatives and
brown people storming the border and uh
what does Trump call them insane asylums
emptying out into the United States and
immigrants taking your jobs and China
taking your stuff and whatever
in order to get them to agree to the
authoritarianism
you say I will use the authoritarianism
to uh help protect you from all these
things I have made you afraid of so fear
gets them to go with the
authoritarianism even when they say I
like freedom I like Liberty secondly
there's ignorance okay
I know people are going to find this
offensive to some degree the magas will
find this offensive there are a lot of
these folks particularly Trump's
followers that don't know what is
happening and so when they are told hey
you know what I can fix this thing I've
made you afraid of if you just give me
the power to do why I'll protect you
from X if you give me the power to do
why
they don't understand that it's just not
going to happen it's just not gonna I
will protect you from China by passing
tariffs
well but the tariffs are paid by
American come they don't know so they go
yes protect us from China by passing the
tariffs or I will protect you from brown
people raping women and children and
taking your jobs with a wall sure that
yeah sounds like that'll work I will
support you because of that and so
ignorance allows the authoritarianism to
grow and grow and grow
and then thirdly and I think sort of uh
uh you know finally here is the desire
for power the right sees many of these
authoritarian leaders and ideas as a way
to gain and maintain power over others a
power which they feel justified in
wanting because they believe that they
are morally correct and correct on
policy and whatever the case may be they
believe we would be the ones in charge
under such a system we would rather
freedom and liberty we would but
everything other than what we believe in
is really dangerous and we're scared of
it and it's whatever and so since we
would be the ones in power then it's
okay to impose this authoritarianism and
uh that that is the way that it would
ultimately stay now these are
generalizations not all right-wingers
are attracted to authoritarianism the
ones that are might only be motivated by
fear and their ignorance rather than
desire for power
or maybe it's desire for power and fear
and they're not really ignorant but
they've just miscalculated in some way
this is why the American right wing
overall on average is attracted to
authoritarianism and then you have two
more elements to this yes there's the
double standard okay they claim to be
about small government except when they
say oh no no the government needs to
tell Twitter exactly what to do wait I
thought you were against regulation yeah
but except when they're censoring
conservatives on Twitter but are they no
but that doesn't matter they've already
bought into that so there's the double
standard and then secondly I think in
this kind of addendum it's also
important to understand the connection
between right Wingers supporting
authoritarianism and populist rhetoric
and I've spoken before
about how populism is not a set of
policies it is a rhetoric and it's a way
of talking to people there is left-wing
populism and right-wing populism and
again some people go no there isn't
David
there is populist rhetoric from the
right and left
the populist rhetoric from the right is
often used to justify horrible things
right Bernie and Tucker Carlson will
both say the middle class has been
screwed and passed over and not helped
the way it should have been in this
country for a long time great a lot of
people will agree with that Tucker will
say and so to protect you from that we
have to keep the dirty poor immigrants
out and prevent antifa from taking your
house or whatever the case may be that's
important not to ignore
which is that much of the support for
its authoritarianism from the right has
come on the heels of populist rhetoric
from right wing Heroes Heroes to them
like Tucker and Trump and others that's
my sense of the love affair with
authoritarianism in the modern American
right wing I welcome your comments uh to
go beyond that let me know in an email
let me know in a comment we'll do a
follow-up soon
one of our sponsors today is fume fume's
mission is to help people cut out the
bad habits fume is not a vape there's no
nicotine fume is a wooden non-electric
device that delivers plant flavored air
and gives you something to do with your
hands that's it instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
a delicious satisfying Sensation that
really is powerful it has an adjustable
airflow dial a magnetic end cap so it
always gives your fingers something to
do people trying to conquer bad habits
know exactly how important those factors
are sometimes you have to replace a
negative habit with the benign one to
accomplish your goal read the reviews
online thousands of people are talking
about how fume is the perfect
alternative for that hand to mouth
fixation head over to trifum.com and use
the code Pacman to save 10 when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below